à inviter cette tunnel dispositif
exceptionnel comme sur les chaînes infos
je suis en mesure de vous révéler le
couloir dans lequel a marché il y a
encore quelques secondes Elisabeth borne
la première ministre avant de se rendre
devant l'entrée du studio en attendant
de répondre à vos questions elle est ici
elle attend passer sur le grill et d'ici
là elle profite de sa vapoteuse goût
pop-corn cassis ce soir sans réforme le
régime de retraite accuserait un déficit
de 13,5 milliards d'euros en 2030 la
réforme qui consiste donc à repousser
cet âge de départ de 62 à 64 ans était
censé elle rapporter presque 18
milliards d'euros donc vous voyez à peu
près 13 milliards de déficit 18
milliards d'euros de 7 ça nous laissait
un petit peu moins de 5 milliards
d'euros au départ de gain les personnes
en invalidité par exemple ou considéré
comme inapte ne sont pas concernés par
cette réforme des retraites elle
continueront de partir à 62 ans donc ça
coûte 3 milliards il y a eu tous les
aménagements sur carrière longue ils
sont millions les petites retraites un
milliard 8 parce qu'il fait que de
proche sont proches c'est Olivier du
soft d'ailleurs qu'il a reconnu hier
dans le Parisien l'équilibre financier
de notre système à l'horizon 2030
s'éloigne un dubitablement louis Boyard
député un soumis et opposant à la
réforme des retraites l'ancien concours
pour demain on lance le hashtag blocus
challenge postez vos plus belles photos
de blocus de lycée et d'université le
gagnant tir au sort pourra visiter
l'hémicycle en compagnie de l'élu
réaction indignée de ces députés de la
majorité la politique n'est pas un
challenge Tik Tok riposte la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale autre lot a
gagné une visite d'un commissariat selon
ce syndicat policier qui rappelle que
bloquera un établissement scolaire
est-il légal vous savez Louis Boyard est
député de la troisième circonscription
du Val-de-Marne
c'est la circonscription historique d'un
grand politique français qui s'appelait
Roger Gérard Schwarzenberg qui était le
président du MRG quand on voit le la
descente là c'est plus des déclins c'est
de la décadence de notre pays voilà moi
je j'ai même pas envie de m'énerver
tellement ça me désespère dehors
on est dans la descendance totale quoi
c'est transformer
dans des endroits chiants genre les âgés
en un truc un peu plus populaire et fans
c'est le hanounisme qui est aujourd'hui
une tendance politique très importante
en France
qui est porté à la fonction
parlementaire son titre ce qui se passe
chez Hanouna et ben là aujourd'hui dans
la vie politique française on a
transposé le studio de Cyril Hanouna
dans la vie parlementaire on se comporte
de la même façon on dit les mêmes
aberrations on fait les mêmes on
respecte rien
[Musique]
responsables français qui travaillent le
plus dur le ministre du Travail lui
continue de défendre sa réforme une
réforme de gauche assure-t-il à la une
du Parisien je sais pas si c'est une
réforme de gauche ou de droite je sais
pas vous savez je pense que peut-être
traditionnellement la droite porte des
réformes des retraites fondées sur le
décalage de l'âge légal
des réformes portées sur l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation ce type est un
petit militante un petit clown c'est un
petit péteux c'est un petit pain de
voilà et il s'avère que le suffrage
c'est le suffrage universel permet en
France que des individus de catégorie
soit élu et c'est heureux et c'est
heureux il est aussi élu démocratie
il y a plein de gens qui rêveraient de
rien faire et de gagner de en faisant
rien la reine de la vache à
[Applaudissements]
douille
vous expliquer aux gens que vous êtes
privilégié mais il va falloir bosser le
samedi le dimanche il va falloir bosser
Noël va falloir bosser en noir décalé va
falloir vous trouverez candidats arrêtez
le samedi le dimanche Noël arrêtez parce
que à chaque fois que je pose la
question combien parce que noël c'est
une fois dans l'année oui d'abord
c'est le dimanche au Philippe nous
appelle de l'Oise bonjour Philippe
que faites-vous dans la vie Philippe
de métro bientôt à la retraite le 1er
août à quel âge 51 ans et 8 mois
51 ans avec une décote et je vais partir
j'ai pas honte et j'ai pas honte et je
n'étais pas voler moi il y a 23 ans
bosser le dimanche je trouvais ça
effectivement super génial voilà il y a
entre temps je me suis marié j'ai eu des
gosses et je peux vous dire bah beau
gosse ils sont à la maison le samedi
dimanche parce que la semaine ils sont à
l'école
depuis le 1er janvier vous allez
travailler combien de dimanche voilà
j'ai pas travaillé de dimanche qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait monsieur si vous êtes
centenaire par exemple qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire pendant 49 ans
49 ans
avec tout ce que j'ai respiré depuis
plus de 30 piges puisqu'on a des
analyses qui devaient arriver ça fait
plus de 20 ans on a toujours rien et on
n'a pas besoin de résultats des analyses
on sait très bien tout ce qu'on a
respirer pendant 30 ans et c'est comme
ça et puis on peut rien y faire donc ça
m'est arrivé que je sois bien Emmanuel
Macron lors de son discours de remise a
dit que pour vous Isabelle la recette de
l'équilibre c'était une moitié de
travail et une moitié de travail et le
remède à la fatigue cette encore le
travail
je vous confirme mais pas de là à parler
d'enfer non ton gars qui a appelé tout à
l'heure qui a pris sa retraite à 51 ans
le conducteur de métro ce sont nos tins
de cotisations sociales et patronales
qui servent à payer le fait que pendant
49 ans ce gars ne va rien faire de ses
journées donc excusez-moi mais
c'est une c'est une image
il nous reste quelques secondes encore
Élisabeth borne est-ce qu'il a des
sujets ou des annonces que vous aimeriez
faire et qui pourraient justifier qu'on
vous conserve en quelque minutes après
la pause publicitaire alors je sais pas
juste
15 secondes on n'aurait pas le temps
vous restez quelques secondes avec nous
voilà dans un instant les dernières
annonces d'Élisabeth borne juste après
la possibilité pardon mais voilà c'est
France Télévision c'est service public
il faut faire rentrer de l'argent après
20h c'est impossible je pense qu'on peut
faire plus fort que le 31 janvier
dernier qui était déjà la plus grosse
mobilisation depuis le début des années
90 et j'appelle ce matin l'ensemble des
citoyens à se mobiliser demain dans
toutes les manifestations